The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at ocw.
mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So last week, last
few lectures, you heard about
parallel architectures and
started with lecture four on
discussions of concurrency.
How do you take applications
or independent actors that
want to operate on the
same data and make
them run safely together?
And so just recapping the last
two lectures, you saw really
two primary classes
of architectures.
Although Saman talked
about a few more.
There was the class of shared
memory processors, you know,
the multicores that Intel, AMD,
and PowerPC, for example,
have today, where you have
one copy of the data.
And that's really shared among
all the different processors
because they essentially
share the same memory.
And you need things like
atomicity and synchronization
to be able to make sure that the
sharing is done properly
so that you don't get into data
race situations where
multiple processors try to
update the same data element
and you end up with
erroneous results.
You also heard about distributed
memory processors.
So an example of that might be
the Cell, loosely said, where
you have cores that primarily
access their own local memory.
And while you can have a single
global memory address
space, to get data from memory
you essentially have to
communicate with the different
processors to explicitly fetch
data in and out.
So things like data
distribution, where the data
is, and what your communication
pattern is like
affect your performance.
So what I'm going to talk about
in today's lecture is
programming these two
different kinds of
architectures, shared memory
processors and distributed
memory processors, and present
you with some concepts for
commonly programming
these machines.
So in shared memory processors,
you have, say, n
processors, 1 to n.
And they're connected
to a single memory.
And if one processor asks for
the value stored at address X,
everybody knows where
it'll go look.
Because there's only one address
X. And so different
processors can communicate
through shared variables.
And you need things like
locking, as I mentioned, to
avoid race conditions or
erroneous computation.
So as an example of
parallelization, you know,
straightforward parallelization
in a shared
memory machine, would be you
have the simple loop that's
just running through an array.
And you're adding elements of
array A to elements of array
B. And you're going to write
them to some new array, C.
Well, if I gave you this loop
you can probably recognize
that there's really no data
dependencies here.
I can split up this loop into
three chunks -- let's say I
have three processors -- where
one processor does all the
computations for iterations
zero through three, so the
first four iterations.
Second processor does the
next four iterations.
And the third processor does
the last four iterations.
And so that's shown with the
little -- should have brought
a laser pointer.
So that's showing here.
And what you might need to
do is some mechanism to
essentially tell the different
processors, here's the code
that you need to run and
maybe where to start.
And then you may need some way
of sort of synchronizing these
different processors that say,
I'm done, I can move on to the
next computation steps.
So this is an example of a data
parallel computation.
The loop has no real
dependencies and, you know,
each processor can operate
on different data sets.
And what you could do is you
can have a process --
this is a single application
that forks off or creates what
are commonly called
the threads.
And each thread goes on and
executes in this case the same
computation.
So a single process can create
multiple concurrent threads.
And really each thread is just
a mechanism for encapsulating
some trace of execution,
some execution path.
So in this case you're
essentially encapsulating this
particular loop here.
And maybe you parameterize
your start index and your
ending index or maybe
your loop bounds.
And in a shared memory
processor, since you're
communicating --
since there's only a single
memory, really you don't need
to do anything special about
the data in this particular
example, because everybody knows
where to go look for it.
Everybody can access it.
Everything's independent.
There's no real issues with
races or deadlocks.
So I just wrote down some actual
code for that loop that
parallelize it using Pthreads,
a commonly
used threading mechanism.
Just to give you a little bit
of flavor for, you know, the
complexity of -- the simple loop
that we had expands to a
lot more code in this case.
So you have your array.
It has 12 elements.
A, B, and C. And you have
the basic functions.
So this is the actual code
or computation that we
want to carry out.
And what I've done here is
I've parameterized where
you're essentially starting
in the array.
So you get this parameter.
And then you calculate four
iterations' worth.
And this is essentially the
computation that we're
carrying out.
And now in my main program or
in my main function, rather,
what I do is I have this concept
of threads that I'm
going to create.
In this case I'm going to
create three of them.
There are some parameters that
I have to pass in, so some
attributes which are now
going to get into here.
But then I pass in the
function pointer.
This is essentially a mechanism
that says once I've
created this thread, I go to
this function and execute this
particular code.
And then some arguments
that are functions.
So here I'm just passing in an
index at which each loop
switch starts with.
And after I've created each
thread here, implicitly in the
thread creation, the
code can just
immediately start running.
And then once all the threads
have started running, I can
essentially just exit
the program
because I've completed.
So what I've shown you with
that first example was the
concept of, or example
of, data parallelism.
So you're performing the same
computation, but instead of
operating on one big chunk of
data, I've partitioned the
data into smaller chunks
and I've replicated the
computation so that I can get
that kind of parallelism.
But there's another form of
parallelism called control
parallelism, which essentially
uses the same model of
threading but doesn't
necessarily have to run the
same function or run the same
computation each thread.
So I've sort of illustrated
that in the illustration
there, where these are your data
parallel computations and
these are some other
computations in your code.
So there is sort of a
programming model that allows
you to do this kind of
parallelism and tries to sort
of help the programmer by taking
their sequential code
and then adding annotations that
say, this loop is data
parallel or this set of code
is has this kind of control
parallelism in it.
So you start with your
parallel code.
This is the same program,
multiple data kind of
parallelization.
So you might have seen in the
previous talk and the previous
lecture, it was SIMD, single
instruction or same
instruction, multiple data,
which allowed you to execute
the same operation, you
know, and add over
multiple data elements.
So here it's a similar
kind of terminology.
There's same program, multiple
data, and multiple program,
multiple data.
This talk is largely focused on
the SPMD model, where you
essentially have one central
decision maker or you're
trying to solve one central
computation.
And you're trying to parallelize
that over your
architecture to get the
best performance.
So you start off with your
program and then you annotate
the code with what's parallel
and what's not parallel.
And you might add in some
synchronization directives so
that if you do in fact have
sharing, you might want to use
the right locking mechanism
to guarantee safety.
Now, in OpenMP, there are
some limitations as
to what it can do.
So it in fact assumes
that the programmer
knows what he's doing.
And the programmer is largely
responsible for getting the
synchronization right, or that
if they're sharing that they
get those dependencies
protected correctly.
So you can take your program,
insert these annotations, and
then you go on and
test and debug.
So a simple OpenMP example,
again using the simple loop --
now, I've thrown away some of
the extra code -- you're
adding these two extra
pragmas in this case.
The first one, your parallel
pragma, I call the data
parallel pragma, really says
that you can execute as many
of the following code block as
there are processors or as
many as you have thread
contexts.
So in this case I implicitly
made the assumption that I
have three processors, so I can
automatically partition my
code into three sets.
And this transformation can sort
of be done automatically
by the compiler.
And then there's a for pragma
that says this loop is
parallel and you can divide up
the work in the mechanism
that's work sharing.
So multiple threads can
collaborate to solve the same
computation, but each one does
a smaller amount of work.
So this is in contrast to what
I'm going to focus on a lot
more in the rest of our talk,
which is distributed memory
processors and programming
for distributed memories.
And this will feel a lot more
like programming for the Cell
as you get more and more
involved in that and your
projects get more intense.
So in distributed memory
processors, to recap the
previous lectures, you
have n processors.
Each processor has
its own memory.
And they essentially share the
interconnection network.
Each processor has its own
address, X. So when a
processor, P1, asks for X it
knows where to go look.
It's going to look in its
own local memory.
So if all processors are asking
for the same value as
sort of address X, then each
one goes and looks in a
different place.
So there are n places
to look, really.
And what's stored in those
addresses will vary because
it's everybody's local memory.
So if one processor, say P1,
wants to look at the value
stored in processor two's
address, it actually has to
explicitly request it.
The processor two has
to send it data.
And processor one has to figure
out, you know, what to
do with that copy.
So it has to store
it somewhere.
So this message passing really
exposes explicit communication
to exchange data.
And you'll see that there are
different kinds of data
communications.
But really the concept of what
you exchange has three
different -- or four different,
rather --
things you need to address.
One is how is the data
described and
what does it describe?
How are the processes
identified?
So how do I identify that
processor one is
sending me this data?
And if I'm receiving data
how do I know who I'm
receiving it from?
Are all messages the same?
Well, you know, if I send a
message to somebody, do I have
any guarantee that it's
received or not?
And what does it mean for a send
operation or a receive
operation to be completed?
You know, is there some sort
of acknowledgment process?
So an example of a message
passing program -- and if
you've started to look at the
lab you'll see that this is
essentially where the
lab came from.
It's the same idea.
I've created -- here I have some
two-dimensional space.
And I have points in this
I have points B, which are these
blue circles, and I have
points A which I've represented
as these yellow or
golden squares.
And what I want to do is for
every point in A I want to
calculate the distance to all
of the points B. So there's
sort of a pair wise interaction
between the two arrays.
So a simple loop that
essentially does this --
and there are n squared
interactions, you have, you
know, a loop that loops over
all the A elements, a loop
that loops over all
the B elements.
And you essentially calculate
in this case Euclidean
distance which I'm
not showing.
And you store it into
some new array.
So if I give you two processors
to do this work,
processor one and processor
two, and I give you some
mechanism to share between
the two --
so here's my CPU.
Each processor has
local memory.
What would be some approach
for actually
parallelizing this?
Anybody look at the lab yet?
OK, so what would you do
with two processors?
AUDIENCE: One has half
memory [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
So what was said was that you
split one of the arrays in two
and you can actually get that
kind of concurrency.
So, you know, let's
say processor one
already has the data.
And it has some place that it's
already allocated where
it's going to write C, the
results of the computation,
then I can break up the work
just like it was suggested.
So what P1 has to do
is send data to P2.
It says here's the data.
Here's the computation.
Go ahead and help me out.
So I send the first array
elements, and then I send half
of the other elements
that I want the
calculations done for.
And then P1 and P2 can
now sort of start
computing in parallel.
But notice that P2 has its own
array that it's going to store
results in.
And so as these compute they
actually fill in different
logical places or logical parts
of the overall matrix.
So what has to be done is at the
end for P1 to have all the
results, P2 has to send it sort
of the rest of the matrix
to complete it.
And so now P1 has
all the results.
The computation is done
and you can move on.
Does that make sense?
OK.
So you'll get to actually do
this as part of your labs.
So in this example messaging
program, you have started out
with a sequential code.
And we had two processors.
So processor one actually
sends the code.
So it is essentially a template
for the code you'll
end up writing.
And it does have to work
in the outer loop.
So this n array over which it
is iterating the A array, is
it's only doing half as many.
And processor two has to
actually receive the data.
And it specifies where to
receive the data into.
So I've omitted some things, for
example, extra information
sort of hidden in these
parameters.
So here you're sending all of
A, all of B. Whereas, you
know, you could have specified
extra parameters that says,
you know, I'm sending you A.
Here's n elements to read from
A. Here's B. Here's n by
two elements to read
from B. And so on.
But the computation is
essentially the same except
for the index at which you
start, in this case changed
for processor two.
And now, when the computation is
done, this guy essentially
waits until the data
is received.
Processor two eventually sends
it that data and now
you can move on.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So would processor two
have to wait for the data
from processor one?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
so there's a --
I'll get into that later.
So what does it mean
to receive?
To do this computation, I
actually need this instruction
to complete.
So what does it need for that
instruction to complete?
I do have to get the data
because otherwise I don't know
what to compute on.
So there is some implicit
synchronization
that you have to do.
And in some cases
it's explicit.
So I'll get into that
a little bit later.
Does that sort of hint
at the answer?
Are you still confused?
AUDIENCE: So processor one
doesn't do the computation but
it still sends the data --
PROFESSOR: So in terms of
tracing, processor one sends
the data and then can
immediately start executing
its code, right?
Processor two, in this
particular example, has to
wait until it receives
the data.
So once this receive completes,
then you can
actually go and start executing
the rest of the code.
So imagine that it essentially
says, wait until I have data.
Wait until I have
something to do.
Does that help?
AUDIENCE: Can the
main processor
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
PROFESSOR: Can the
main processor --
AUDIENCE: I mean, in Cell,
everybody is not peers.
There is a master there.
And what master can do instead
of doing computation, master
can be basically the
quarterback, sending data,
receiving data.
And SPEs can be basically
waiting for data, get the
computation, send it back.
So in some sense in Cell you
probably don't want to do the
computation on the master.
Because that means the
master slows down.
The master will do only
the data management.
So that might be one symmetrical
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: And you'll see
that in the example.
Because the PPE in that case
has to send the data to two
different SPEs.
Yup?
AUDIENCE: In some sense
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
at points seems to be
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] sense that if
-- so have a huge array
and you want to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] the
data to receive the whole
array, then you have
to [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, we'll
get into that later.
Yeah, I mean, that's
a good point.
You know, communication
is not cheap.
And if you sort of don't take
that into consideration, you
end up paying a lot
for overhead for
parallelizing things.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, you can do
things in software as well.
We'll get into that.
OK, so some crude performance
analysis.
So I have to calculate
this distance.
And given two processors, I can
effectively get a 2x speedup.
By dividing up the work I can
get done in half the time.
Well, if you gave me four
processors, I can maybe get
done four times as fast. And
in my communication model
here, I have one copy of one
array that's essentially
sending to every processor.
And there's some subset of A.
So I'm partitioning my other
array into smaller subsets.
And I'm sending those to each
of the different processors.
So we'll get into terminology
for how to actually name these
communications later.
But really the thing to take
away here is that this
granularity -- how I'm
partitioning A -- affects my
performance and communication
almost directly.
And, you know, the comment that
was just made is that,
you know, what do you do
about communication?
It's not free.
So all of those will
be addressed.
So to understand performance,
we sort of summarize three
main concepts that you
essentially need to
understand.
One is coverage, or in other
words, how much parallelism do
I actually have in
my application?
And this can actually affect,
you know, how much work is it
worth spending on this
particular application?
Granularity --
you know, how do you partition
your data among your different
processors so that you can keep
communication down, so
you can keep synchronization
down, and so on.
Locality --
so while not shown in the
particular example, if two
processors are communicating, if
they are close in space or
far in space, or if the
communication between two
processors is far cheaper than
two other processors, can I
exploit that in some way?
And so we'll talk about
that as well.
So an example of sort of
parallelism in an application,
there are two essentially
projects that are doing ray
tracing, so I thought I'd
have this slide here.
You know, how much parallelism
do you have in
a ray tracing program.
In ray tracing what you do is
you essentially have some
camera source, some observer.
And you're trying to figure out,
you know, how to color or
how to shade different pixels
in your screen.
So what you do is you shoot rays
from a particular source
through your plane.
And then you see how the rays
bounce off of other objects.
And that allows you to render
scenes in various ways.
So you have different kinds of
parallelisms. You have your
primary ray that's shot in.
And if you're shooting into
something like water or some
very reflective surface, or some
surface that can actually
reflect, transmit, you can
essentially end up with a lot
more rays that are created
at run time.
So there's dynamic parallelism
in this particular example.
And you can shoot a lot
of rays from here.
So there's different kinds of
parallelism you can exploit.
Not all prior programs have this
kind of, sort of, a lot
of parallelism, or
embarrassingly parallel
computation.
You know, you saw
some basic code
sequences in earlier lectures.
So there's a sequential part.
And the reason this is
sequential is because there
are data flow dependencies
between each of the different
computations.
So here I calculate a, but I
need the result of a to do
this instruction.
I calculate d here and I need
that result to calculate e.
But then this loop really here
is just assigning or it's
initializing some big array.
And I can really do
that in parallel.
So I have sequential parts
and parallel parts.
So how does that affect
my overall speedups?
And so there's this law which
is really a demonstration of
diminishing returns,
Amdahl's Law.
It says that if, you know, you
have a really fast car, it's
only as good to you as fast
as you can drive it.
So if there's a lot of
congestion on your road or,
you know, there are posted speed
limits or some other
mechanism, you really can't
exploit all the
speed of your car.
Or in other words, you're only
as fast as the fastest
mechanisms of the computation
that you can have.
So to look at this in more
detail, your potential speedup
is really proportional to the
fraction of the code that can
be parallelized.
So if I have some computation
-- let's say it has three
parts: a sequential part that
takes 25 seconds, a parallel
part that takes 50 seconds,
and a sequential part that
runs in 25 seconds.
So the total execution
time is 100 seconds.
And if I have one processor,
that's really all I can do.
And if she gave me more than one
processor -- so let's say
I have five processors.
Well, I can't do anything about
the sequential work.
So that's still going
to take 25 seconds.
And I can't do anything about
this sequential work either.
That still takes 25 seconds.
But this parallel part I can
essentially break up among the
different processors.
So five in this case.
And that gets me, you know,
five-way parallelism.
So the 50 seconds now is
reduced to 10 seconds.
Is that clear so far?
So the overall running time in
that case is 60 seconds.
So what would be my speedup?
Well, you calculate speedup,
old running time divided by
the new running time.
So 100 seconds divided
by 60 seconds.
Or my parallel version
is 1.67 times faster.
So this is great.
If I increase the number of
processors, then I should be
able to get more and
more parallelism.
But it also means that there's
sort of an upper bound on how
much speedup you can get.
So if you look at the fraction
of work in your application
that's parallel, that's p.
And your number of processors,
well, your speedup is --
let's say the old running time
is just one unit of work.
If the time it takes for the
sequential work -- so that's 1
minus p, since p is the fraction
of the parallel work.
And it's the time to do
the parallel work.
And since I can parallelize
that fraction over n
processors, I can sort of reduce
that to really small
amounts in the limit.
Does that make sense so far?
So the speedup can tend to 1
over 1 minus p in the limit.
If I increase the number of
processors or that gets really
large, that's essentially my
upper bound on how fast
programs can work.
You know, how much can I exploit
out of my program?
So this is great.
What this law says -- the
implication here is if your
program has a lot of inherent
parallelism, you
can do really well.
But if your program doesn't have
any parallelism, well,
there's really nothing
you can do.
So parallel architectures
won't really help you.
And there's some interesting
trade-offs, for example, that
you might consider if you're
designing a chip or if you're
looking at an application or
domain of applications,
figuring out what is the best
architecture to run them on.
So in terms of performance
scalability, as I increase the
number of processors,
I have speedup.
You can define, sort of,
an efficiency to
be linear at 100%.
But typically you end up in sort
of the sublinear domain.
That's because communication
is not often free.
But you can get super linear
speedups ups on real
architectures because of
secondary and tertiary effects
that come from register
allocation or caching effects.
So they can hide a lot of
latency or you can take
advantage of a lot of pipelining
mechanisms in the
architecture to get super
linear speedups.
So you can end up in two
different domains.
So a small, you know, overview
of the extent of parallelism
in your program and
how that affects
your overall execution.
And the other concept
is granularity.
So given that I have this
much parallelism, how
do I exploit it?
There are different ways of
exploiting it, and that comes
down to, well, how do I
subdivide my problem?
What is the granularity of the
sub-problems I'm going to
calculate on?
And, really, granularity from
my perspective, is just a
qualitative measure of what is
the ratio of your computation
to your communication?
So if you're doing a lot of
computation, very little
communication, you could
be doing really
well or vice versa.
Then you could be computation
limited, and so you need a lot
of bandwidth for example
in your architecture.
AUDIENCE: Like before, you
really didn't have to give
every single processor
an entire copy of B.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yeah.
Good point.
And as you saw in the previous
slides, you have --
computation stages
are separated by
communication stages.
And your communication in a
lot of cases essentially
serves as synchronization.
I need everybody to get to the
same point before I can move
on logically in my
computation.
So there are two kinds of sort
of classes of granularity.
There's fine grain and, as
you'll see, coarse grain.
So in fine-grain parallelism,
you have low computation to
communication ratio.
And that has good properties
in that you have a small
amount of work done between
communication stages.
And it has bad properties in
that it gives you less
performance opportunity.
It should be more, right?
More opportunity for --
AUDIENCE: No.
Less.
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
Yeah, yeah, sorry.
I didn't get enough sleep.
So less opportunities for
performance enhancement, but
you have high communication
ratio because essentially
you're communicating
very often.
So these are the computations
here and these yellow bars are
the synchronization points.
So I have to distribute
data or communicate.
I do computations but,
you know, computation
doesn't last very long.
And I do more communication or
more synchronization, and I
repeat the process.
So naturally you can adjust this
granularity to sort of
reduce the communication
overhead.
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
two things in that
overhead part.
One is the volume.
So one, communication.
Also there's a large part
of synchronization cost.
Basically you get a
communication goal and you
have to go start the messages
and wait until
everybody is done.
So that overhead also can go.
Even if you don't send that much
data, just the fact that
you are communicating, that
means you have to do a lot of
this additional bookkeeping
stuff, that especially in the
distributed [? memory ?]
[? machine is ?] pretty
expensive.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Thanks.
So in coarse-grain parallelism,
you sort of make
the work chunks more and
more so that you do the
communication synchronization
less and less.
And so that's shown here.
You do longer pieces of
work and have fewer
synchronization stages.
So in that regime, you can have
more opportunities for
performance improvements, but
the tricky thing that you get
into is what's called
load balancing.
So if each of these different
computations takes differing
amounts of time to complete,
then what you might end up
doing is a lot of people might
end up idle as they wait until
everybody's essentially reached
their finish line.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: If you don't have to
acknowledge that something's
done can't you just say, [?
OK, I'm done with
your salt ?].
Hand it to the initial
processor
and keep doing whatever?
PROFESSOR: So, you can do
that in cases where that
essentially there is a
mechanism -- or the
application allows for it.
But as I'll show -- well, you
won't see until the next
lecture -- there are
dependencies, for example,
that might preclude you
from doing that.
If everybody needs to reach the
same point because you're
updating a large data structure
before you can go
on, then you might not
be able to do that.
So think of doing molecular
dynamics simulations.
You need everybody to calculate
a new position
before you can go on and
calculate new kinds of coarse
interactions.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
nothing else to calculate yet.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: But also there
is pipelining.
So what do you talk about
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] because you
might want to get the next data
while you're computing
now so that when I'm done
I can start sending.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] you
can all have some of that.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Yeah, because communication is
such an intensive part, there
are different ways of
dealing with it.
And that will be right
after load balancing.
So the load balancing problem
is just an illustration.
And things that appear in sort
of this lightish pink will
serve as sort of visual cues.
This is the same color coding
scheme that David's using in
the recitations.
So this is PPU code.
Things that appear in yellow
will be SPU code.
And these are just meant to
essentially show you how you
might do things like this on
Cell, just to help you along
in picking up more of the syntax
and functionality you
need for your programs.
So in the load balancing
problem, you essentially have,
let's say, three different
threads of computation.
And so that's shown here:
red, blue, and orange.
And you've reached some
communication stage.
So the PPU program in this case
is saying, send a message
to each of my SPEs, to each of
my different processors, that
you're ready to start.
And so now once every processor
gets that message,
they can start computing.
And let's assume they have data
and so on ready to go.
And what's going to happen is
each processor is going to run
through the computation
at different rates.
Now this could be because
one processor
is faster than another.
Or it could be because
one processor is
more loaded than another.
Or it could be just because
each processor is assigned
sort of differing
amounts of work.
So one has a short loop.
One has a longer loop.
And so as the animation shows,
sort of, execution proceeds
and everybody's waiting until
the orange guy has completed.
But nobody could have made
progress until everybody's
reached synchronization point
because, you know, there's a
strict dependence that's being
enforced here that says, I'm
going to wait until everybody's
told me they're
done before I go on to the
next step of computation.
And so you know, in Cell
you do that using
mailboxes in this case.
That clear so far?
So how do you get around this
load balancing problem?
Well, there are two
different ways.
There's static load balancing.
I know my application
really, really well.
And I understand sort of
different computations.
So what I can do is I can divide
up the work and have a
static mapping of the work
to my processors.
And static mapping just means,
you know, in this particular
example, that I'm going to
assign the work to different
processors and that's what
the processors will do.
Work can't shift around
between processors.
And so in this case I
have a work queue.
Each of those bars is
some computation.
You know, I can assign some
chunk to P1, processor one,
some chunk to processor two.
And then computation
can go on.
Those allocations
don't change.
So this works well if I
understand the application,
well and I know the computation,
and my cores are
relatively homogeneous and, you
know, there's not a lot of
contention for them.
So if all the cores are the
same, each core has an equal
amount of work -- the total
amount of work -- this works
really well because nobody
is sitting too idle.
It doesn't work so well for
heterogeneous architectures or
multicores.
Because one might be faster
than the other.
It increases the complexity of
the allocation I need to do.
If there's a lot of contention
for some resources, then that
can affect the static
load balancing.
So work distribution might
end up being uneven.
So the alternative is dynamic
load balancing.
And you certainly could do
sort of a hybrid load
balancing, static plus
dynamic mechanism.
Although I don't have
that in the slides.
So in the dynamic load
balancing scheme, two
different mechanisms I'm
going to illustrate.
So in the first scheme, you
start with something like the
static mechanism.
So I have some work going
to processor one.
And I have some work going
to processor two.
But then as processor two
executes and completes faster
than processor one, it takes on
some of the additional work
from processor one.
So the work that was here
is now shifted.
And so you can keep helping
out, you know, your other
processors to compute
things faster.
In the other scheme, you have
a work queue where you
essentially are distributing
work on the fly.
So as things complete, you're
just sending them
more work to do.
So in this animation
here, I start off.
I send work to two different
processors.
P2 is really fast so it's just
zipping through things.
And then P1 eventually finishes
and new work is
allocated to the two
different schemes.
So dynamic load balancing is
intended to sort of give equal
amounts of work in a different
scheme for processors.
So it really increased
utilization and spent less and
less time being idle.
OK.
So load balancing was one part
of sort of how granularity can
have a performance trade-off.
The other is synchronization.
So there were already some good
questions as to, well,
you know, how does this play
into overall execution?
When can I wait?
When can't I wait?
So I'm going to illustrate it
with just a simple data
dependence graph.
Although you can imagine that
in each one of these circles
there's some really heavy
load computation.
And you'll see that in the
next lecture, in fact.
So if I have some simple
computation here --
I have some operands.
I'm doing an addition.
Here I do another addition.
I need both of these results
before I can do this
multiplication.
Here I have, you know, some
loop that's adding through
some array elements.
I need all those results before
I do final substraction
and produce my final result.
So what are some synchronization
points here?
Well, it really depends on how
I allocate the different
instructions to processors.
So if I have an allocation that
just says, well, let's
put all these chains on one
processor, put these two
chains on two different
processors, well, where are my
synchronization points?
Well, it depends on where this
guy is and where this guy is.
Because for this instruction
to execute, it needs to
receive data from P1 and P2.
So if P1 and P2 are different
from what's in that box,
somebody has to wait.
And so there's a
synchronization that has to happen.
So essentially at all join
points there's potential for
synchronization.
But I can adjust the granularity
so that I can
remove more and more
synchronization points.
So if I had assigned all this
entire sub-graph to the same
processor, I really get rid of
the synchronization because it
is essentially local to that
particular processor.
And there's no extra messaging
that would have to happen
across processors that says,
I'm ready, or I'm ready to
send you data, or you can move
on to the next step.
And so in this case the last
synchronization point would be
at this join point.
Let's say if it's allocated on
P1 or on some other processor.
So how would I get rid of this
synchronization point?
AUDIENCE: Do the whole thing.
PROFESSOR: Right.
You put the entire thing
on a single processor.
But you get no parallelism
in this case.
So the coarse-grain, fine-grain
grain parallelism
granularity issue
comes to play.
So the last sort of thing I'm
going to talk about in terms
of how granularity impacts
performance -- and this was
already touched on -- is that
communication is really not
cheap and can be quite
overwhelming on a lot of
architectures.
And what's interesting about
multicores is that they're
essentially putting a lot
more resources closer
together on a chip.
So it essentially is changing
the factors for communication.
So rather than having, you know,
your parallel cluster
now which is connected, say,
by ethernet or some other
high-speed link, now you
essentially have large
clusters or will have large
clusters on a chip.
So communication factors
really change.
But the cost model is relatively
captured by these
different parameters.
So what is the cost of
my communication?
Well, it's equal to, well, how
many messages am I sending and
what is the frequency with
which I'm sending them?
There's some overhead
for message.
So I have to actually package
data together.
I have to stick in a control
header and then send it out.
So that takes me some work
on the receiver side.
I have to take the message.
I maybe have to decode the
header, figure out where to
store the data that's coming
in on the message.
So there's some overhead
associated with that as well.
There's a network delay for
sending a message, so putting
a message on the network so that
it can be transmitted, or
picking things up
off the network.
So there's a latency also
associated with how long does
it take for a message to get
from point A to point B. What
is the bandwidth that I
have across a link?
So if I have a lot of bandwidth
then that can really
lower my communication cost. But
if I have little bandwidth
then that can really
create contention.
How much data am I sending?
And, you know, number
of messages.
So this numerator here is really
an average of the data
that you're sending
per communication.
There's a cost induced
per contention.
And then finally there's
-- so all of
these are added factors.
The higher they are, except for
bandwidth, because it's in
the denominator here,
the worse your
communication cost becomes.
So you can try to reduce the
communication cost by
communicating less.
So you adjust your
granularity.
And that can impact your
synchronization or what kind
of data you're shipping
around.
You can do some architectural
tweaks or maybe some software
tweaks to really get the network
latency down and the
overhead per message down.
So on something like raw
architecture, which we saw in
Saman's lecture, there's a
really fast mechanism to
communicate your nearest
neighbor in three cycles.
So one processor can send a
single operand to another
reasonably fast. You know, you
can improve the bandwidth
again in architectural
mechanism.
You can do some tricks as to how
you package your data in
each message.
And lastly, what I'm going to
talk about in a couple of
slides is, well, I can also
improve it using some
mechanisms that try
to increase the
overlap between messages.
And what does this
really mean?
What am I overlapping it with?
And it's really the
communication and computation
stages are going to somehow
get aligned.
So before I actually show you
that, I just want to point out
that there are two kinds
of messages.
There's data messages, and these
are, for example, the
arrays that I'm sending around
to different processors for
the distance calculations
between points in space.
But there are also
control messages.
So control messages essentially
say, I'm done, or
I'm ready to go, or is there
any work for me to do?
So on Cell, control messages,
you know, you can think of
using Mailboxes for those and
the DMAs for doing the data
communication.
So data messages are relatively
much larger --
you're sending a lot of data
-- versus control messages
that are really much shorter,
just essentially just sending
you very brief information.
So in order to get that overlap,
what you can do is
essentially use this concept
of pipelining.
So you've seen pipelining
in superscalar.
Someone talked about that.
And what you are essentially
trying to do is break up the
communication and computation
into different stages and then
figure out a way to overlap
them so that you can
essentially hide the
latency for the
sends and the receives.
So let's say you have some work
that you're doing, and it
really requires you to
send the data --
somebody has to send you the
data or you essentially have
to wait until you get it.
And then after you've waited and
the data is there, you can
actually go on and
do your work.
So these are color coded.
So this is essentially one
iteration of the work.
And so you could overlap them
by breaking up the work into
send, wait, work stages, where
each iteration trying to send
or request the data for the next
iteration, I wait on the
data from a previous iteration
and then I do my work.
So depending on how I partition,
I can really get
really good overlap.
And so what you want to get to
is the concept of the steady
state, where in your main loop
body, all you're doing is
essentially pre-fetching or
requesting data that's going
to be used in future iterations
for future work.
And then you're waiting on --
yeah.
I think my color coding
is a little bogus.
That's good.
So here's an example of how
you might do this kind of
buffer pipelining in Cell.
So I have some main loop that's
going to do some work,
that's encapsulating
this process data.
And what I'm going to
use is two buffers.
So the scheme is also called
double buffering.
I'm going to use this ID to
represent which buffer I'm
going to use.
So it's either buffer
zero or buffer one.
And this instruction here
essentially flips the bit.
So it's either zero or one.
So I fetch data into buffer zero
and then I enter my loop.
So this is essentially the first
send, which is trying to
get me one iteration ahead.
So I enter this mail loop and
I do some calculation to
figure out where to write
the next data.
And then I do another request
for the next data item that
I'm going to -- sorry, there's
an m missing here --
I'm going to fetch data into
a different buffer, right.
This is ID where I've already
flipped the bit once.
So this get is going to write
data into buffer zero.
And this get is going to write
data into buffer one.
I flip the bit again.
So now I'm going to issue a wait
instruction that says is
the data from buffer
zero ready?
And if it is then I can go on
and actually do my work.
Does that make sense?
People are confused?
Should I go over it again?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So this
is an [? x or. ?]
So I could have just said buffer
equals zero or buffer
equals one.
Oh, sorry.
This is one.
Yeah.
So this is a one here.
Last-minute editing.
It's right there.
Did that confuse you?
AUDIENCE: No.
But, like, I don't
see [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh.
OK.
So I'll go over it again.
So this get here is going
to write into ID zero.
So that's buffer zero.
And then I'm going
to change the ID.
So imagine there's a one here.
So now the next time I use ID,
which is here, I'm trying to
get the data.
And I'm going to write
it to buffer one.
The DMA on the Cell processor
essentially says I can send
this request off and I can check
later to see when that
data is available.
But that data is going to go
into a different buffer,
essentially B1.
Whereas I'm going to work
on buffer zero.
Because I changed the
ID back here.
Now you get it?
So I fetch data into buffer
zero initially
before I start to loop.
And then I start working.
I probably should have had
an animation in here.
So then you go into
your main loop.
You try to start fetching into
buffet one and then you try to
compute out of buffer zero.
But before you can start
computing out of buffer zero,
you just have to make sure
that your data is there.
And so that's what the
synchronization is doing here.
Hope that was clear.
OK, so this kind of computation
and communication
overlap really helps in
hiding the latency.
And it can be real useful
in terms of improving
performance.
And there are different kinds
of communication patterns.
So there's point to point.
And you can use these both for
data communication or control
communication.
And it just means that, you
know, one processor can
explicitly send a message
to another processor.
There's also broadcast that
says, hey, I have some data
that everybody's interested in,
so I can just broadcast it
to everybody on the network.
Or a reduce, which
is the opposite.
It says everybody on the network
has data that I need
to compute, so everybody
send me their data.
There's an all to all, which
says all processors should
just do a global exchange of
data that they have. And then
there's a scatter
and a gather.
So a scatter and a gather are
really different types of
broadcast. So it's one to
several or one to many.
And gather, which
is many to one.
So this is useful when you're
doing a computation that
really is trying to pull data
in together but only from a
subset of all processors.
So it depends on how you've
partitioned your problems.
So there's a well-known sort
of message passing library
specification called MPI that
tries to specify all of these
different communications in
order to sort of facilitate
parallel programming.
Its full featured actually has
more types of communications
and more kinds of functionality
than I showed on
the previous slides.
But it's not a language or
a compiler specification.
It's really just a library
that you can implement in
various ways on different
architectures.
Again, it's same program,
multiple data, or supports the
SPMD model.
And it works reasonably well for
parallel architectures for
clusters, heterogeneous
multicores, homogeneous
multicores.
Because really all it's doing
is just abstracting out --
it's giving you a mechanism
to abstract out all the
communication that you would
need in your computation.
So you can have additional
things like precise buffer
management.
You can have some collective
operations.
I'll show an example of for
doing things things in a
scalable manner when a lot of
things need to communicate
with each other.
So just a brief history of
where MPI came from.
And, you know, very early
when, you know, parallel
computers started becoming more
and more widespread and
there were these networks and
people had problems porting
their applications or writing
applications for these
[? came, ?] just because it was
difficult, as you might be
finding in terms of programming
things with the
Cell processor.
You know, there needed to be
ways to sort of address the
spectrum of communication.
And it often helps to have a
standard because if everybody
implements the same standard
specification, that allows
your code to be ported
around from one
architecture to the other.
And so MPI came around.
The forum was organized
in 1992.
And that had a lot of people
participating in it from
vendors, you know, people like
IBM, a company like IBM,
Intel, and people who had
expertise in writing
libraries, users who were
interested in using these
kinds of specifications to
do their computations, so
scientific people who were
in the scientific domain.
And it was finished in
about 18 months.
I don't know if that's a
reasonably long time or a
short time.
But considering, you know, I
think the MPEG-4 standard took
a bit longer to do, as
a comparison point.
I don't have the actual data.
So point-to-point
communication --
and again, a reminder, this is
how you would do it on Cell.
These are SPE sends
and receives.
You have one processor
that's sending
it to another processor.
Or you have some network
in between.
And processor A can essentially
send the data
explicitly to processor two.
And the message in this case
would include how the data is
packaged, some other information
such as the length
of the data, destination,
possibly some tag so you can
identify the actual
communication.
And, you know, there's an actual
mapping for the actual
functions on Cell.
And there's a get for the send
and a put for the receive.
So there's a question of, well,
how do I know if my data
actually got sent?
How do I know if it
was received?
And there's, you know, you can
think of a synchronous send
and a synchronous receive, or
asynchronous communication.
So in the synchronous
communication, you actually
wait for notification.
So this is kind of like
your fax machine.
You put something
into your fax.
It goes out and you eventually
get a beep that says your
transmission was OK.
Or if it wasn't OK then, you
know, you get a message that
says, you know, something
went wrong.
And you can redo your
communication.
An asynchronous send is
kind of like your --
AUDIENCE: Most [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
you could get
a reply too.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you
can get a reply.
Thanks.
An asynchronous send, it's like
you write a letter, you
go put it in the mailbox, and
you don't know whether it
actually made it into the actual
postman's bag and it
was delivered to your
destination or if it was
actually delivered.
So you only know that the
message was sent.
You know, you put it
in the mailbox.
But you don't know anything else
about what happened to
the message along the way.
There's also the concept
of a blocking versus a
non-blocking message.
So this is orthogonal really
to synchronous versus
asynchronous.
So in blocking messages, a
sender waits until there's
some signal that says the
message has been transmitted.
So this is, for example if I'm
writing data into a buffer,
and the buffer essentially gets
transmitted to somebody
else, we wait until the
buffer is empty.
And what that means is that
somebody has read it on the
other end or somebody has
drained that buffer from
somewhere else.
The receiver, if he's waiting on
data, well, he just waits.
He essentially blocks until
somebody has put
data into the buffer.
And you can get into potential
deadlock situations.
So you saw deadlock with locks
in the concurrency talk.
I'm going to show
you a different
kind of deadlock example.
An example of a blocking
send on Cell --
allows you to use mailboxes.
Or you can sort of use
mailboxes for that.
Mailboxes again are just for
communicating short messages,
really, not necessarily for
communicating data messages.
So an SPE does some work, and
then it writes out a message,
in this case to notify the PPU
that, let's say, it's done.
And then it goes on and
does more work.
And then it wants to notify
the PPU of something else.
So in this case this particular
send will block
because, let's say, the PPU
hasn't drained its mailbox.
It hasn't read the mailbox.
So you essentially stop and wait
until the PPU has, you
know, caught up.
AUDIENCE: So all mailbox
sends are blocking?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
David says yes.
A non-blocking send is something
that essentially
allows you to send a message
out and just continue on.
You don't care exactly about
what's happened to the message
or what's going on with
the receiver.
So you write the data into
the buffer and you
just continue executing.
And this really helps you in
terms of avoiding idle times
and deadlocks, but it might
not always be the
thing that you want.
So an example of sort of a
non-blocking send and wait on
Cell is using the DMAs
to ship data out.
You know, you can put something,
put in a request to
send data out on the DMA.
And you could wait for it if you
want in terms of reading
the status bits to make
sure it's completed.
OK, so what is a source of
deadlock in the blocking case?
And it really comes about if you
don't really have enough
buffering in your communication
network.
And often you can resolve that
by having additional storage.
So let's say I have processor
one and processor two and
they're trying to send messages
to each other.
So processor one sends a message
at the same time
processor two sends a message.
And these are going
to go, let's say,
into the same buffer.
Well, neither can make progress
because somebody has
to essentially drain that buffer
before these receives
can execute.
So what happens with that code
is it really depends on how
much buffering you have
between the two.
If you have a lot of buffering,
then you may never
see the deadlock.
But if you have a really tiny
buffer, then you do a send.
The other person can't do the
send because the buffer hasn't
been drained.
And so you end up
with a deadlock.
And so a potential solution
is, well, you actually
increase your buffer length.
But that doesn't always
work because you can
still get into trouble.
So what you might need to do
is essentially be more
diligent about how you order
your sends and receives.
So if you have processor one
doing a send, make sure it's
matched up with a receive
on the other end.
And similarly, if you're doing
a receive here, make sure
there's sort of a matching
send on the other end.
And that helps you in sort of
making sure that things are
operating reasonably in lock
step at, you know, partially
ordered times.
That was really examples of
point-to-point communication.
A broadcast mechanism is
slightly different.
It says, I have data that I
want to send to everybody.
It could be really efficient
for sending short control
messages, maybe even efficient
for sending data messages.
So as an example, if you
remember our calculation of
distances between all points,
the parallelization strategy
said, well, I'm going
to send one copy of
the array A to everybody.
In the two processor
case that was easy.
But if I have n processors,
then rather than sending
point-to-point communication
from A to everybody else, what
I could do is just, say,
broadcast A to everybody and
they can grab it off
the network.
So in MPI there's this
function, MPI
broadcast, that does that.
I'm using sort of generic
abstract sends, receives and
broadcasts in my examples.
So you can broadcast
A to everybody.
And then if I have n processors,
then what I might
do is distribute the m's in a
round robin manner to each of
the different processes.
So you pointed this out.
I don't have to send
B to everybody.
I can just send, you
know, in this case,
one particular element.
Is that clear?
AUDIENCE: There's no
broadcast on Cell?
PROFESSOR: There is no
broadcast on Cell.
There is no mechanism for
reduction either.
And you can't quite do
scatters and gathers.
I don't think.
OK, so an example of a
reduction, you know, I said
it's the opposite of a
broadcast. Everybody has data
that needs to essentially
get to the same point.
So as an example, if everybody
in this room had a value,
including myself, and I wanted
to know what is the collective
value of everybody in the
room, you all have to
send me your data.
Now, this is important because
if -- you know, in this case
we're doing an addition.
It's an associative operation.
So what we can do is we
can be smart about
how the data is sent.
So, you know, guys that are
close together can essentially
add up their numbers
and forward me.
So instead of getting
n messages I
can get log n messages.
And so if every pair of you
added your numbers and
forwarded me that, that cuts
down communication by half.
And so you can, you know --
starting from the back of
room, by the time you get to
me, I only get two messages
instead of n messages.
So a reduction combines data
from all processors.
In MPI, you know, there's
this function MPI
reduce for doing that.
And the collective operations
are things that are
associative.
And subtract --
sorry.
And or and -- you can read
them on the slide.
There is a semantic caveat here
that no processor can
finish the reduction before all
processors have at least
sent it one data or have
contributed, rather, a
particular value.
So in many numerical algorithms,
you can actually
use the broadcast and send to
broadcast and reduce in place
of sends and receives because
it really improves the
simplicity of your
computation.
You don't have to do n sends
to communicate there.
You can just broadcast. It
gives you a mechanism for
essentially having a shared
memory abstraction on
distributed memory
architecture.
There are things like all to all
communication which would
also help you in that sense.
Although I don't talk about all
to all communication here.
So I'm going to show you an
example of sort of a more
detailed MPI.
But I also want to contrast this
to the OpenMP programming
on shared memory processors
because one might look simpler
than the other.
So suppose that you have a
numerical integration method
that essentially you're going
to use to calculate pi.
So as you get finer and finer,
you can get more accurate --
as you shrink these intervals
you can get
better values for pi.
And the code for doing
that is some C code.
You have some variables.
And then you have a step that
essentially tells you how many
times you're going to
do this computation.
And for each time step you
calculate this particular
function here.
And you add it all up and in the
end you can sort of print
out what is the value of
pi that you calculated.
So clearly as, you know, as you
shrink your intervals, you
can get more and more accurate
measures of pi.
So that translates to increasing
the number of steps
in that particular C code.
So you can use that numerical
integration to calculate pi
with OpenMP.
And what that translates to is
-- sorry, there should have
been an animation here to ask
you what I should add in.
You have this particular loop.
And this is computation that
you want to parallelize.
And there is really four
questions that you essentially
have to go through.
Are there variables
that are shared?
Because you have to get
the process right.
If there are variables that
are shared, you have to
explicitly synchronize them and
use locks to protect them.
What values are private?
So in OpenMP, things that are
private are data on the stack,
things that are defined
lexically within the scope of
the computation that you
encapsulate by an OpenMP
pragma, and what variables
you might want
to use for a reduction.
So in this case I'm doing a
summation, and this is the
computation that I
can parallelize.
Then I essentially want to do
a reduction for the plus
operator since I'm doing an
addition on this variable.
This loop here is parallel.
It's data parallel.
I can split it up.
The for loop is also --
I can do this work
sharing on it.
So I use the parallel
for pragma.
And the variable x
here is private.
It's defined here but I can
essentially give a directive
that says, this is private.
You can essentially rename
it on each processor.
Its value won't have any
effect on the overall
computation because each
computation will have its own
local copy.
That clear so far?
So computing pi with integration
using MPI takes up
two slides.
You know, I could fit it on one
slide but you couldn't see
it in the back.
So there's some initialization.
In fact, I think there's only
six basic MPI commands that
you need for computing.
Three of them are here and
you'll see the others are MPI
send and MPI receive.
And there's one more that you'll
see on the next slide.
So there's some loop
that says while I'm
not done keep computing.
And what you do is you broadcast
n to all the
different processors.
N is really your time step.
How many small intervals of
execution are you going to do?
And you can go through,
do your computation.
So now this -- the MPI
essentially encapsulates the
computation over n processors.
And then you get to an MPI
reduce command at some point
that says, OK, what values
did everybody compute?
Do the reduction on that.
Write that value into my MPI.
Now what happens here is there's
processor ID zero
which I'm going to consider
the master.
So he's the one who's going to
actually print out the value.
So the reduction essentially
synchronizes until everybody's
communicated a value
to processor zero.
And then it can print
out the pi.
And then you can finalize, which
actually makes sure the
computation can exit.
And you can go on
and terminate.
So the last concept in terms of
understanding performance
for parallelism is this
notion of locality.
And there's locality in your
communication and locality in
your computation.
So what do I mean by that?
So in terms of communication,
you know, if I have two
operations and let's say -- this
is a picture or schematic
of what the MIT raw
chip looks like.
Each one of these is a core.
There's some network, some basic
computation elements.
And if I have, you know, an
addition that feeds into a
shift, well, I can put the
addition here and the shift
there, but that means I have a
really long path that I need
to go to in terms
of communicating
that data value around.
So the computation naturally
should just be closer together
because that decreases the
latency that I need to
communicate.
So rather than doing net
mapping, what I might want to
do is just go to somebody who is
close to me and available.
AUDIENCE: Also there
are volume issues.
So assume more than that.
A lot of other people also
want to communicate.
So if [UNINTELLIGIBLE] randomly
distributed, you can
assume there's a lot
more communication
going into the channel.
Whereas if you put locality in
there then you can scale
communication much better than
scaling the network.
PROFESSOR: There's also a notion
of locality in terms of
memory accesses.
And these are potentially also
very important or more
important, rather, because
of the latencies
for accessing memory.
So if I have, you know, this
loop that's doing some
addition or some computation on
an array and I distribute
it, say, over four
processors --
this is, again, let's assume
a data parallel loop.
So what I can do is have a work
sharing mechanism that
says, this thread here
will operate on
the first four indices.
This thread here will operate
on the next four indices and
the next four and
the next four.
And then you essentially get to
join barrier and then you
can continue on.
And if we consider how the
access patterns are going to
be generated for this particular
loop, well, in the
sequential case I'm essentially
generating them in sequence.
So that allows me to exploit,
for example, on traditional
[? CAT ?] architecture, a notion
of spatial locality.
If I look at how things are
organized in memory, in the
sequential case I can
perhaps fetch an
entire block at a time.
So I can fetch all the
elements of A0
to A3 in one shot.
I can fetch all the elements
of A4 to A7 in one shot.
And that allows me to
essentially improve
performance because I overlap
communication.
I'm predicting that once I see
a reference, I'm going to use
data that's adjacent
to it in space.
There's also a notion of
temporal locality that says
that if I use some particular
data element, I'm going to
reuse it later on.
I'm not showing that here.
But in the parallel case what
could happen is if each one of
these threads is requesting a
different data element -- and
let's say execution essentially
proceeds -- you
know, all the threads
are requesting their
data at the same time.
Then all these requests are
going to end up going to the
same memory bank.
The first thread is requesting
ace of zero.
The next thread is requesting
ace of four, the next thread
ace of eight, next
thread ace of 12.
And all of these happen to be
in the same memory bank.
So what that means is, you
know, there's a lot of
contention for that
one memory bank.
And in effect I've serialized
the computation.
Right?
Everybody see that?
And, you know, this can be
a problem in that you can
essentially fully serialize the
computation in that, you
know, there's contention on the
first bank, contention on
the second bank, and then
contention on the third bank,
and then contention on
the fourth bank.
And so I've done absolutely
nothing other than pay
overhead for parallelization.
I've made extra work for
myself [? concreting ?]
the threads.
Maybe I've done some extra
work in terms of
synchronization.
So I'm fully serial.
So what you want to do is
actually reorganize the way
data is laid out in memory so
that you can effectively get
the benefit of parallelization.
So if you have the data
organized as is there, you can
shuffle things around.
And then you end up with fully
parallel or a layout that's
more amenable to full
parallelism because now each
thread is going to
a different bank.
And that essentially gives you
a four-way parallelism.
And so you get the performance
benefits.
So there are different kinds of
sort of considerations you
need to take into account for
shared memory architectures in
terms of how the design affects
the memory latency.
So in a uniform memory access
architecture, every processor
is either, you can think
of it as being
equidistant from memory.
Or another way, it has the
same access latency for
getting data from memory.
Most shared memory architectures
are non-uniform,
also known as NUMA
architecture.
So you have physically
partitioned memories.
And the processors can have the
same address space, but
the placement of data affects
the performance because going
to one bank versus another
can be faster or slower.
So what kind of architecture
is Cell?
Yeah.
No guesses?
AUDIENCE: It's not
a shared memory.
PROFESSOR: Right.
It's not a shared memory
architecture.
So a summary of parallel
performance factors.
So there's three things
I tried to cover.
Coverage or the extent
of parallelism in the
application.
So you saw Amdahl's Law and it
actually gave you a sort of a
model that said when is
parallelizing your application
going to be worthwhile?
And it really boils down to
how much parallelism you
actually have in your particular
algorithm.
If your algorithm is sequential,
then there's
really nothing you can do for
programming for performance
using parallel architectures.
I talked about granularity of
the data partitioning and the
granularity of the work
distribution.
You know, if you had really
fine-grain things versus
really coarse-grain things,
how does that translate to
different communication costs?
And then last thing I
shared was locality.
So if you have near neighbors
talking, that may be different
than two things that are
further apart in space
communicating.
And there are some issues in
terms of the memory latency
and how you actually can
take advantage of that.
So this really is an overview
of sort of the parallel
programming concepts and the
performance implications.
So the next lecture will be,
you know, how do I actually
parallelize my program?
And we'll talk about that.